نعم ولكن لنبدا بالاحدث زين الان وسائل
اعلام اسرائيليه تتحدث عن مقتل احد
الاسرائيليين الذين اصيبا باستهداف صواريخ
مضاده للدروع ل في مبنى استهدف مبنى في
بلده كاريو فال في اصبع الجليل لكن ننتظر
تحديث مؤكد من قبل الاسعاف الاسرائيلي
ولكن هذا ما تتناقله الان وسائل الاعلام
الاسرائيليه بعد ان كانت قد اكدت انه
نتيجه استهداف المبنى بصاروخين مضادين
للدروع على الاقل اصيب اسرائيليين احدهما
سيده اصيبت بجراح حرجه وتم نقلها بطائره
هليكوبتر
لمستشفى ولكن بالطبع قبل ذلك كان خلال
ساعات الصباح قد اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي عن
اصابه خمسه من جنود
ثلاثه وصفت اصابتهم بال الطفيفه واثنان
بال المتوسطه جراء الاشتباك الذي وقع فجر
هذا اليوم مع مقاتلين تسللوا من داخل
الاراضي اللبنانيه تحديدا عند مزارع شبعه
عند القطاع الشرقي من الحدود مع لبنان وا
كانت المصادر قد اكدت الاسرائيليه بالطبع
ونسبه الى الجيش الاسرا
بانه تم القضاء على المقاتلين وتصفيتهم
وعلى الاقل هم اربعه وفق الجيش الاسرائيلي
لكن لم يتم الاعلان عن اصابات ولكن في
ساعات الصباح تم التاكيد بانه كان هناك
على الاقل خمسه من الجنود كما ذكرنا
اصيبوا
بجراح اثنان منهم بجراح متوسطه الان يعني
واضح اننا امام تصعيد بعد هدوء نسبي نو
نوعا ما خلال الايام الماضيه ولكن في هذه
الاثناء ايضا زين نستطيع ان نستمع لدوي
اصوات المدفعيه الاسرائيليه تقوم بقصف
اهداف على الاقل ما نسمعه هنا في القطاع
الشرقي
والاوسط جاء ذلك خلال النصف ساعه الماضيه
وتحديدا بعد استهداف منطقه او بلده كفار
يوفال كما ذكرنا وهي في اصبع الجليل وهو
الاقرب الى الحدود مع لبنان نذكر ايضا ان
رئيس هيئه الاركان الاسرائيليه هرسي
هاليفي كان قد اكد ليله امس بان منطقه
جنوب لبنان اصبحت منطقه قتال اي منطقه حرب
وانه اذا استمر حزب الله بذلك فانه قد
يحول كامل الاراضي اللبنانيه الى منطقه
قتال اي منطقه حرب وبذلك تهديد مبطن
بتوسيع على الاقل هذه الجبهه التي لازالت
بالطبع هي بين كر وفر التواصل لتبادل
اطلاق النار والقذائف على جانبي الحدود